through any public territories so to to
help the change to help China to become
a more democratic society you need
people who who can act who can give out
their opinions and talk to the young
people and trying to find a way to
encourage people to to be involved so
only when you're doing that you can have
a civil society so on
what I'm doing is more
on 20 involve my art with the reality 20
beaut a possible possibility and to
connect art under the social change
since 2005 I started working on Internet
I write blogs and Twitter's and organize
activities through the internet we did
the 2007 fairy tale which is art show in
castle they organised 1001 Chinese to go
over to Germany under the whole
organisation and work is through the
internet which become a very success and
a lot of young people first time earn
they realize the power of and of this
kind of social media and a social
communication and later by 2008 and
China had a huge earthquake and which is
devastating and after the earthquake the
government refused to give out the truth
of who is dead and how many of them
amount of them there's a lot of students
which is crashed by mishandling of the
construction work its victimized by the
corruptions so through the internet we
organized the investigation and we asked
him volunteers to join us under 2:00 to
go to Sutra in the local area at door
backdoor of illegitimate village so
after a year of research we find out
over 5000 to 119 students their name the
first day all the informations which
school they were under and their
families contact so through doing that
we are very encouraged a lot of young
young people to be involved and we in
trying always trying to
remind people on an individual car maker
effort and also make an impact
I think Internet is a very the most
valuable and sin happened because that's
the only way people can freely associate
with others and freely give out
information but the internally China has
a Great Firewall with forbidden any
information decently sensitive so the
struggle is always very and very strong
there because the government basically
censors everything they don't like I
think in next a few years China is faced
in a moment which for the social and the
political change and even through the
past thirty years China made a great
difference economically and to be much
more connected under recognized by the
international community but still we are
still our communist society some basic
values such as freedom of speech and the
human rights which still in poor
condition and many people only because
it's because speak out their mind it can
be put in jail or or it can be putting
very difficult situation and by not to
let people do to be have a freedom to to
get the information and the to to be
freely associated with other people
under to have a free election so the
this whole political situation is still
very corrupted and under the society
sacrifice its environment and education
and the moral stands to just to trying
to become a rich
and that cannot last long and so far we
don't see any real consciousness and
willing to to to make a difference
through the party itself so we can see
through the internet people very aware
of that and but in the reality and you
know even internationally all the
Western nations are trying to kind of
tolerate what happening in China today I
think this is very short-sighted and
this will will not help China to become
a modern society so I think what we can
do as individual is really to use in
Internet and using the new technology
and to communicate this young people and
the tude to have a much broader
discussions and to make the change more
smoothly and to make the change because
it will come and it's not nobody can
really avoid that so I think this is a
time for people to to be more conscious
about that
it's the it's up it's the middle of the
night in China but I believe I Weiwei is
watching live with us now do we see him
there highway way
you